the Joe Rogan experience I don't have
good access to raw milk witty get it
back Oh
health food store like sprouts or you
know something like that
yeah I think they have it at erawan
maybe Whole Foods has it it's like it's
really tricky because you it's not even
legal in some places to have whole milk
in fact people been arrested and and
just locked up for having whole milk yes
google that because it's pretty
preposterous when you think about how
easy it is to buy whiskey right and then
think about people buying whole milk
that whole milk is apparently for some
people I mean it might have to something
to do with skirting FDA regulations and
yeah things along those lines it gets
very complicated for sure and then those
are the reason for homogenous ation and
pasteurization is obviously health right
we're trying to protect people in also
its shelf-life it stays on the Shelf
longer mm-hmm but I've definitely bought
it yeah there's a small what does it
call it a small group food group raw
food club they had they were raided in
2011 mm-hmm for sharing raw milk or
something the latest raw milk raid an
attack on food freedom
federal agents organized a sting
operation against a tiny raw milk buying
Club and ignore more serious food safety
concerns yeah like Twinkies I mean how
hard is it look you can I'm sure get
poop food poisoning from spoiled milk
right but isn't spoiled milk yogurt
ultimately right well here's what I do
with food if it stinks I don't eat it
good move bro yeah and I think milk you
smell pretty quickly if it's going bad
this involved unwashed room-temperature
eggs the other count unwashed
room-temperature eggs a storage method
Rossum members prefer by the way when we
had chickens for these nasty coyotes
killed all my chickens we would store
our eggs at room temperature we put them
in a bowl we would wash the outside of
the egg and put them in a bowl and they
would sit on the counter and I was
eating them all day long
nothing happened healthiest [ __ ] Asians
dumped gallons of raw milk and filled a
large flatbed with the seized food
including coconuts we seized your
[ __ ] coconuts watermelons and frozen
buffalo meat what the [ __ ] like what is
this agents who are these [ __ ] that
are getting paid government money from
our taxes to steal frozen frozen meat
jesus christ christopher darden who
helped prosecute oj simpson appeared at
Stuart's arraignment just in time to
lower his bail all right so Christopher
Darden is out there helping people
whatever gross it's just to grow I mean
I don't think you should you know we
should somehow or another find out
whether there's a way to test if this
raw milk is fresh enough for people to
eat but if it is people live on farms
have been drinking raw milk since the
beginning of time it's normal and
healthy it tastes better
it's it's way easier for you to digest
like I get a little weird when I drink
like straight like if I have milk and
cookies which I live um I don't know
what me it's a cookie soy milk hmm I
might be full of [ __ ] here and I'm
thinking about it the cookies might be
what's messing with my stomach I don't
think so though because you get this
feeling from the milk like uh it's
probably both
another thing about it's both well in
France you get the the unpasteurized
cheese yes my friend jean-marc used to
bring it back in his luggage he would
smuggle back for a rock lot you know
what that is yeah it's like a dish that
he would make with meat and cheese yeah
that's good but I don't hear the French
dying in droves they seem to be healthy
as [ __ ] and then I was fat right yeah
their bread is better they have bread
that is not from there they're they
don't have modern wheat so the wheat
that they have is not engineered to have
more complex glutens and and higher
yield like we do
[Applause]